the White House this morning is
preparing for a fight with congressional
Democrats but we're Special Counsel
Robert Mulder's final report on Russian
interference the 2016 election it is
front-page news across the country as
one would imagine now a summary released
by Attorney General William bar says
Muller found no collusion between
President Trump or his campaign in
Russia Democrats want to know why Muller
did not say whether the President
believes the president the president
obstructed justice bars letter says
there's enough evidence to prove that
there's no no there's not enough
evidence agree with that I knew it you
met the Russian investigation lasted 22
months producing more than 2,800
subpoenas and about 500 witness
interviews it cost more than 25 million
dollars and led to criminal charges for
a number of people connected to mr.
Trump plus 25 Russians and three Russian
companies major Garrett is at the White
House where lawyers are still waiting to
see the report but the President
believes that he was completely cleared
and he is saying so major I hear they
are celebrating at the White House today
good morning good morning in numerous
conversations yesterday with lawyers and
advisors the president Trump was by
turns elated at the no collusion
conclusion but still seething that this
investigation was launched in the first
place the president and many close to
him still regard the special counsel
probe as a nasty political power play
advisers are urging the President to
turn the page and look for ways to work
with Congress even as congressional
Democrats say based on what they've seen
so far they are neither satisfied nor
convinced it's time for America to move
forward I don't care what side of the
aisle you are Republican Republican
lawmakers overnight declared case closed
on the Russia probe and the president
House Minority Leader Kevin McCarthy
accused Democrats of acting
irresponsibly history will not support
the idea of what they just put America
through going for the last 22 months
North Carolina's Mark Meadows tweeted
the clock has finally struck midnight on
the Russia collusion fantasy unburdened
of the Russia investigation for the
first time the president returned to the
White House late Sunday upbeat America
is the
greatest place on earth the special
council concluded the investigation did
not establish that members of the Trump
campaign conspired or coordinated with
the Russian government in its election
interference activities and a four page
summary Attorney General William Barr
repeated some variation of that phrase
five times the Trump team piled on he
didn't
Moeller previously charged 25 Russian
nationals with attempting to influence
the election bar summary emphasized
there was no sign the Trump campaign
conspired in those efforts quote despite
multiple offers from Russian affiliated
individuals this knocked down the
central allegation of Russian collusion
that launched the probe to be honest
it's a shame that the president has had
to go through this four before I even
got elected it began Moeller also
investigated whether the president
obstructed justice during the
investigation and reached a murky
conclusion there was no obstruction and
then whatsoever
it was a complete and total exoneration
in fact the special counsel said while
this report does not conclude that the
president committed a crime it also does
not exonerate him Muller left it to
Barre and Deputy Attorney General Rod
Rosenstein to decide the obstruction
question the two White House appointees
decided the evidence is not sufficient
to establish that the president
obstructed justice the president has not
been exonerated by the special counsel
we will ask the Attorney General to
testify before the House Judiciary
Committee Democrats like Judiciary
Committee Chairman Jerry Nadler seized
on those uncertainties we're going to
move forward with our investigations the
president's legal team has had many
different players but one consistent
strategy cooperate with the special
counsel and though the president chafed
with that strategy sometimes that
strategy prevailed the White House
provided more than 20,000 pages of
documents and interviews with more than
30 White House officials and when bars
summary surfaced yesterday the legal
team felt that the president and it had
been vindicated
bianna and worth noting that the
president never had to sit down with the
special counsel either they view that as
a victory as well major thank you